the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
so I wanted to give you guys a survey of
radiation utilizing technology and tell
you a little bit about the way this
department has changed the way it
teaches it used to be in our department
and probably everywhere else around the
country that first we teach you the
theory of how things go down and
understand them and then we can teach
you the context in which they're placed
this resulted in a rather boring
curriculum in my opinion having been one
of the ones that went through this
actual curriculum so for those who don't
know I was an undergrad in this
department and while I learned a lot of
great things from folks I also kept some
mental notes on what I would do
differently and now it's the chance to
do this so instead we've adopted a
context first Theory second approach
which means we tell you where we're
going to show you why should you pay
attention to the rest of the semester
then we fill out the rest of the theory
that fill in the gaps and then revisit
the context to show you what you've
learned and how you can understand it
that's why today is gonna be a rather
light class so don't take any notes just
listen enjoy ask questions and I'm going
to show you some of the applications
where we use radiation and the
principles of NSA in technology today
and for recitation today since we
haven't gone over any technical material
we're going to be heading to my lab to
demonstrate one of these things a
sputter coder which is a controlled
system for radiation damage which
applies one material to the other via
the process of sputtering or actual
nuclear or ionic collisions that blast
material in this case gold on to
whatever you want to coat which in this
case is a pile of pocket change so we're
gonna make some gold change today so the
motivation today is really to get over
to questions is how can radiation be
used for benefit and what is the physics
behind how it can be used I'll be using
a circle a fuel rod the same kinds that
you'd see in a nuclear reactor as the
pointer cuz I'm not a fan of lasers and
this is actually incredibly light like I
can hold it out at the end not much
visible shaking and I wanted you guys to
see and feel and try and Bend what
Zircaloy actually is like that's a piece
the same diameter and dimensions and
stuff that you would see in a nuclear
reactor so give it a slight Bend you
know if you try really hard you can bend
it but notice how light it is notice how
strong it is it's about midway and
between stainless steel and aluminum but
it's a hell of a lot stronger than
aluminum it also has the added benefit
that it basically doesn't absorb
neutrons the real reason we use Zircaloy
or zirconium alloys and reactors is that
they have very low interaction
probabilities or cross-sections and for
those who don't know what those are in a
couple of weeks we'll be defining what a
cross-section is this stuff's pretty
cool also what makes this nuclear grade
Zircaloy and not just regular zirconium
is that there's no hafnium in it hafnium
is chemically very similar to zirconium
it also happens to be one of the highest
cross-section elements that there is so
you'd hate the stuff that you need to be
Neutron eclis transparent in reactors it
happens to be found in the ground with
the last thing you'd want in your fuel
cladding in fact you can use hafnium as
a control rod or control blade so the
difference in in chemistry and and cost
between nuclear zirconium what you've
got there and regular zirconium as the
hafnium has been taken out by some very
painful chemical separation usually
you'd find about three or four percent
hafnium so there's all sorts of
technologies that we use the principles
of nuclear science and engineering I'm
just going to say NSC from now on you're
all probably pretty familiar with power
and may be familiar with some of these
other ones like medical isotopes are the
backbone of a lot of imaging techniques
to find and treat different maladies
space is basically a giant maelstrom of
radiation so you can both use it and you
have to shield from it we'll go over
some of the crazier ways of shielding
from space radiation actually today
semiconductors
the way that the MIT reactor made about
60% of its operating budget until
recently was by irradiating crystals of
silicon single crystal bulls or ingots
of silicon to make what's called an
n-type semiconductor via the following
reaction if I can find an eraser
I'm gonna use the shorthand that we
talked about last time normally you
would take silicon and you add a neutron
and you end up forming phosphorus I've
not memorized the masses of the isotopes
but in the end this is actually a
neutron capture reaction and then a
resulting decay which produces
phosphorus which is what's also known as
an n-type dopant it's a sort of extra
negative so does that a negative charge
type dopant that changes the
conductivity of the semiconductor
there's lots of different ways of doping
semiconductors one of the best and most
uniform is to stick things in the
reactor so back when silicon ingots were
smaller like four or six inches in
diameter there was a constant train of
these things traveling through the
reactor getting irradiated and being
sold and then cut up into wafers to make
devices and it used to be student or
you're off jobs to load and unload those
things from the reactor now it's not
that dangerous as long as you use the
right handling procedures like put them
on a cart pull the cart at arm's length
and push like that your dose is very low
and that's because for a given point
source emitter the dose you receive
drops off as one over R or the distance
squared which means that your arms
length let's say your arm is about a
meter you can drop the dose by quite a
bit compared to what's called the
contact dose well this poor fool held
the silicon ingots up to their chest
like that they were okay they got about
ten months of their yearly allowable
radiation dose that won't induce any
additional risk of cancer but to insure
that they would not exceed that
allowable dose they became the
administrative assistant for the reactor
for the next ten months so their job at
the reactor was to answer the phone
which is not a radioactive activity
including at the reactor first nuclear
power the reason why I know a number of
you guys are here is pretty simple it's
just a hot bucket of water the way we
make that bucket of water hot is by
putting uranium or other fuel into these
rods assembling a lot of them in a small
space where they then heat up by
producing nuclear fission capturing the
resultant kinetic energy of the fission
products and neutrons and everything
else that comes out and using it to
either heat up or boil water that's then
just driven through a heat exchanger and
a turbine so aside from everything on
this side it looks basically like any
other water-cooled power plant
the difference is things get toasty in a
radioactive sense but also pretty well
under control and what's inside a
reactor if you say this is the diagram
of a typical pressurized water reactor
or PWR where the water is pressurized
enough so as to stop boiling from
occurring keeping the water liquid which
is has a number of safety implications
you've got the core of the reactor right
here and these things right here are
called steam generators it's nothing
more than a heat exchanger that
generates steam and the steam generated
in here goes off somewhere else and
drives the turbine if you look inside
this reactor you'll notice a lot of
different fuel assemblies or fuel rods
including things like control rods or
shut down rods rods made of Neutron
absorbers like hafnium that we talked
about or gadolinium or boron for carbide
or any other material with a high
capture cross-section meaning a high
probability for capturing a neutron
rather than letting it go from one fuel
element to another to produce more
fission to produce more heat that's
effectively how a reactor works so we
went over a little bit about the fuel
the fission and the energetics is kind
of cool so let's say you start off with
uranium probably the fissile isotope 235
and you send in one Neutron think it's
92 don't quote me on that though and
instead of undergoing some sort of a
capture reaction or something else it
can split into what we call different
fission products and plus anywhere
between 2 or 3 neutrons the usually
accepted number is an average of about
2.4 for neutrons plus gamma rays plus
anti neutrinos plus other energy and
some occasional other stuff the main
point here is these fission products
if let's say you had a uranium nucleus
and it were to split in half fission
products go in other directions they
carry with them quite a lot of kinetic
energy and what we'll be doing a lot in
the second half of this course is
watching to see how do these highly
energetic nuclei or atoms when they slam
into other atoms how quickly do they
lose energy how far do they tend to go
these fission products tend to stop in
the fuel their range is going to be on
the order of nanometers I don't even
think it reaches microns but the
neutrons however as we saw from looking
at Chadwicks paper they can go pretty
far usually on the order of around 10
centimeters in a reactor before they go
do something else so it might make it a
few fuel rods over and chances are get
captured by another uranium nucleus
making more fission more neutrons and
some other fun stuff like gamma rays and
neutrinos anyone not know what a
neutrino is so a neutrino is a very very
low mass but not massless as was found I
think like last year almost speed of
light particle that's released as part
of radioactive decay they basically
don't interact with matter but once in a
while they do what that means is that
they travel straight through everything
it's been estimated that trillions of
neutrinos from space are passing through
us per second and on average you won't
get a single interaction during a day in
fact to detect neutrinos they've had to
fill old hollowed out salt mines with
water and fill them with photo tubes in
the hopes of catching two or three a day
what that means is if someone turns on a
reactor somewhere anywhere in the world
it's releasing tons and tons of
neutrinos and if all of a sudden you
start to see two or three coming from
the same place that's a rare event
that's something with some statistical
significance and there's been projects
in are still in our department using
neutrino detectors to try and detect
where reactors are turning on anywhere
in the world so we've been able to sense
that the MIT reactor is next door from
the building next door I don't know how
well this is going to work when you get
to farther distances but the physics is
pretty much there it's an engineering
problem to figure out well how do you
detect
neutrinos to get a statistically
significant signal that's far as I know
has not been solved hopefully by this
time next year it will
there's also control rods rods filled
with absorbers like I mentioned before
if you want to stop this nuclear
reaction you send in something like
hafnium or gadolinium or boron so let's
say boron 11 like chadwick knew would be
able to capture a neutron and then it
would turn into what's the next one over
well sorry that's a 1 and a 0 that's a 5
that should turn into carbon-12 and then
you've captured the neutron instead of
letting it get into more uranium and
cause additional fissions so when
something's going wrong or you want to
control the power level and the reactor
you insert control rods they soak up the
neutrons and make the reactor go
subcritical and we'll go over what all
these words mean in due time various
points in the course there's also
coolant and what's called moderation
does anyone know what I mean by
moderation of neutrons yeah what do you
mean
it's thermal eise's them and in other
words it slows them down because the
probability that each uranium nucleus
can capture a neutron depends on the
energy of the neutron the cross-sections
for interaction which we give the symbol
Sigma for the microscopic or sort of
mass independent cross-section they're
functions of energy they're extremely
strong functions of energy over the
energy ranges were interested in because
we're interested in an extremely large
energy range these neutrons tend to be
born at around one to ten MeV or mega
electron volts and by the time they
thermalize like you said or reach
roughly room-temperature kinetic
energies of about 2200 meters per second
they can be a what is it a fortieth or
point oh two five evey fraction of an
electron volt so we're interested in
nine orders of magnitude of energy and
the cross-sections vary wildly over
these nine orders of magnitude and I'll
show you what some of these look like
pretty soon and in this case in the case
of light water reactors like the PWR we
saw the coolant and the moderator are
basically the same thing you guys
remember how when Chadwick put the
paraffin in front of the neutron source
he started to see more ionizations
that's because the paraffin is a great
source of hydrogen so is water water is
an ideal coolant because it takes a lot
of energy to heat it up and a lot to
boil it so you can store a lot of energy
with less of a temperature difference in
water and it's full of hydrogen and
kinematically it's easier for something
the size of a neutron and the mass of a
neutron to slow a neutron down because a
neutron hitting a proton can transfer up
to all of its energy ballistically then
that proton won't move very far because
it's also got charge on it if a neutron
hits something heavier like stainless
steel or other stuff in the reactor it
cannot by conservation of energy and
momentum transfer all of its energy that
fraction is actually pretty small so
you'll see we'll actually calculate what
that fraction is but it drops off pretty
precipitously as you start to get
heavier than hydrogen and finally
there's a reflection and shielding we'll
get into shielding and
terms of how much stuff and how much
matter does it take to stop radiation
from getting through in some cases you
could stop at all in some cases like
gammas you technically never can you'll
just get what's called attenuation or
continuous removal of gamma rays but
chances are you can't remove every
single photon from getting out it's only
a matter of how much do you need it to
get down to and there's a neat aside who
here has looked down into a nuclear
reactor before three of you Wow four
okay what did you see
not that much this is a particularly
powerful reactor known as the advanced
test reactor or ATR at the Idaho
National Laboratory you won't see any
others that look like this one because
these crazy shaped fuel elements are not
that easy to make this is a test or a
research reactor where things get
irradiated it's about a hundred
twenty-five megawatts and the blue light
being produced is called Cherenkov
radiation
it's from electrons and things moving or
beta particles electrons moving faster
than the speed of light in water now as
you know you can't exceed the speed of
light in a vacuum but things can move
through other media faster than the
speed of light in that medium
effectively producing optical shock
waves given off as little blue cones of
light for each particle so when folks
say Oh am I going to go green when I get
near radiation you can say no you'll
glow blue they've just got the wrong
color on all the TV shows and then onto
fusion energy since most of us tend to
talk about fission a lot of the time but
how many of you here are interested in
going into fusion usually it's at least
half the class and so I figured this
used to be a fairly fission centric
teaching style in the department and I
think fusion deserves equal time because
about an equal number of you want to go
into fusion to make it a reality these
reactors are laid out fairly differently
what they'll be is a big hollow vacuum
chamber that shaped like a donut or a
torus and lots of magnets to confine a
plasma or sort of a charged mess of
separated ions and electrons that whirls
around at millions of meters per second
once in a while these ions and electrons
are the especially these nuclei will
collide
with each other and undergo a fusion
reaction or one of a few fusion
reactions that I've written up here for
you so in this case there's no elements
with a symbol D or T we're just using
those to refer to deuterium or tritium
as a visual aid but you should know that
they're deuterium and tritium from their
atomic numbers 1 which means it's an
isotope of hydrogen and their mass
numbers 2 and 3 which is not the mass
number for a normal hydrogen and in this
case when you fuse deuterium and tritium
you can produce helium and another
neutron and so then those neutrons can
be used to hit lithium what they'll
usually have in what's called a breeder
blanket around the outside which
releases more tritium so fusion reactors
actually can produce their own fuel the
trick is they're radioactive gases so
containing them can be kind of tricky
you also need a way to get the helium
out of the reactor but we have one of
these on campus we have one of the only
three in the country it's called the
Alka tour ciment have any of you guys
seen a tour of this place yet almost all
of you so forever who hasn't do it this
year because this may be the last year
of Alka Tour seen mods operation that's
not to say there won't be the next
fusion device on campus but there's one
here right now and it might be a while
before the next one's built so if you
haven't seen it yet go and see it this
semester definitely the reason why
fission and fusion work from an
energetic standpoint is we look at the
binding energy per nucleon remember last
time we mentioned the binding energy is
the difference in energy if you were to
take let's say a proton and a neutron
from infinitely far away and bring them
together to create a nucleus of
deuterium we'll call this D these two
the energy of the proton plus the energy
of the neutron the rest mass energy
rather would be greater than the energy
of just deuterium and that little bit of
mass that's change is converted into
energy and this is what's known as the
binding energy if we look at the binding
energy per nucleon or per proton or
neutron we can get a relative rank
of how tightly bound each nucleus is so
for the light isotopes smashing them
together should liberate excess binding
energy or sorry excess energy because
you'll gain back some of that energy by
the conversion of mass to energy same
thing over on this side there's not as
extreme of a gradient if you were to
split apart heavy nuclei like
uranium-235
you can release a little bit of energy
in fission and once you get up here to
iron you can't go either way which is
why if you think about the biggest
fusion reactors that exist in the
universe anyone know what they are stars
right they tend to hit cores of iron
before they either die out or go all
gravity crazy and become black holes of
supernovas or whatever you will this is
kind of the energetic limit for normal
nuclear processes or if they become a
neutron star then things get beyond the
scope of this course I won't be
explaining neutron stars there's a lot
of medical uses of radiation I don't
know if any of you guys have seen these
things it's the only time I'll show a
tricky looking biology diagram because
it's kind of interesting just note these
are what's called brachytherapy seeds
little seeds of isotopes that remit a
certain type and energy of radiation
selected for their applicability that
can be implanted in the body at the site
of a tumor to deliver localized
radiation treatment you can either go in
through existing ports on the human and
not having to drill or cut a hole in
someone or they can be implanted
laparoscopically or surgically so this
way if you don't want to subject someone
to a whole body radiation dose or
chemotherapy or if you want to use it in
conjunction with chemotherapy you can
implant a tiny little seed of a
radioactive material in there to deliver
a certain dose to a tumor and then take
it out and that way you know very very
well what the dose is going to be
because you can measure the activity or
the number of decays per second of that
Brockie therapy seed and you know how
it's going to change over time because
you know the half-life of the particular
isotope that you've looked at there's
also things like imaging you can have
someone ingest an isotope like
technetium-99 metastable to highlight
certain organs or things in the body
that you
then image later by their decay gamma
rays or other phenomena it's also one of
those reasons why when you go in an
airport you have to tell them if you've
had a medical imaging procedure because
a lot of these places have radiation
detectors and if you are radioactive and
don't identify yourself you will quickly
be identified and taken into the
backroom to the probe you later or
whatever they're going to do with the
airport's I don't know I've never been
searched I don't plan on that happening
there's also x-ray and proton therapy
sending in well known well energy
characterized radiation to fry tumors or
other things in the case of x-rays you
are relying on what's called exponential
attenuation if you look at the distance
into a material and you look at the
intensity of the x-rays say at x equals
zero this is your x-ray source this is
your incoming intensity it falls off
exponentially with distance you might
then ask yourself all right if my tumor
is this deep and I apply that radiation
dose to the tumor what about the rest
what about the part of the body that the
x-rays have traveled through in order to
get to that site anyone know how you
would deliver more x-rays to a tumor
than the surrounding tissue anyone have
any ideas yeah
exactly go from different angles so the
Rays would intersect on the tumor I'll
have a better diagram but I'll draw one
for now
let's say that's the eyes and that's the
tumor you can wear this helmet wear
x-rays can come in from all different
angles and the x-ray emission emitter
would have to come in from different
angles so that as all the Rays intersect
this part gets fried the most while
keeping you from getting too much
radiation to the rest of your brain and
ceasing to function
there's also radiotracers I think I
already covered those so imaging we
already showed an image of what this
looks like the first x-ray back in 1895
didn't have that good resolution but it
was kind of striking in that you could
see the difference in contrast between
bones and tissue
I should replace this with the x-ray of
my foot that was my signing bonus at MIT
my first day on the job I went down to
clean one of the old rooms in Northwest
13 which is now where my labs are and I
moved a bunch of boxes aside and a
200-pound steel plate jagged cut with
plasma torch went down and smashed down
on the bones of my foot and I had one of
those you know temporary feats of
superhuman strength and was able to lift
it up I went back to trying to lift it
up and couldn't move it an inch I don't
know how I got out of the plate the next
thing I remember I was crawling up the
stairs to go to the hospital but I did
get an x-ray and they were able to sense
that the pain and my foot was due to a
hairline fracture it was like a fracture
in the bones that basically came back
together but the improvement in contrast
resolution and x-rays is what
differentiates the ability to see a
hairline fracture from just the ability
to see that you contain bones and the
reason for this and we'll be looking at
a lot of these curves in this course is
the differential absorption or
attenuation of x-rays or any photons of
any energy through different types of
matter and so for example here we have
the ICR you standardized average soft
tissue attenuation as well as bone and
you notice that there's a few
differences in these curves so also
there's some similarities I'll note that
these actually have the same axis of the
same units
what do you guys notice that's the same
about these curves how about the value
they're basically the same mass averaged
with very little differences if you look
at where it hits the y-axis about 3
times 10 to the 3rd 3 times 10 to the
3rd the curves follow basically the same
shape what's the differences so Sean
what do you think these jagged edges
right here anyone have any idea why and
these reasons go back to what you
learned in high school in 802 in terms
of atomic transitions not nuclear anyone
here remember the K lines or the L lines
or though it was at the which emissions
series were they called the different
emission lines that you can get from
missioner absorption spectra it all has
to do with allowable electron
transitions and notice the units here
are in centimeter squared per gram
what's the main difference between soft
tissue and bone say it loud enough so I
can hear density bone tends to be a fair
bit denser than soft tissue so these are
mass outwards that mass normalized
curves but the fact is if you have bone
that has a higher density then you're
going to end up with more absorption in
addition you can use some of these
features and differences to your
advantage like if you choose a photon
with energy here it might not be nearly
as absorbing in soft tissue as it
wouldn't bone so by selecting the mass
of the thing you're trying to image what
you don't control and the energy of the
photon which you can control you can
produce as much possible contrast as you
can between two different things
is everyone clear on how that could work
cool we'll be going over why the kerbs
has these shapes especially these jagged
edges pretty soon and like you said this
is how you irradiated with x-rays
because you can't quite control the
amount of dose to any one part and
you split it up into a whole bunch of
different Ray's proton therapy is quite
different it's a newer technology and it
relies on very well-known and distinct
ranges of charge particles to enter the
body with very little damage stop and do
their damage in the tumor and not come
out the other side they just require
significantly more expensive hardware
there's one of these at Mass General
Hospital or MGH down the road it has
consists of a cyclotron or a particle
accelerator which injects and speeds up
protons so that they're moving very fast
then sends it in a beam through a bunch
of bending magnets and up to deliver the
protons to the patient the way this
works is you start injecting the beam
and as it goes through these two magnets
or what's called DS every time it moves
through the magnet it's a charged
particle in a magnetic field it has a
fixed curvature but every time it's
accelerated through this electric field
it speeds up so the curvature gets
greater and greater and greater and it
spins outwards in a spiral until they
exit the beam and by deciding how long
they get to spin you get to choose the
energy of the protons why depress proton
therapy work this has to do with the
difference in interaction between
charged particles and photons which have
no charge charged particles will lose
their energy in a very well-known way
what's called the stopping power formula
until they actually stop in the matter
that they are going through photons
either scatter or attenuate or they
don't and you can't stop them all so I
want to run a quick Monte Carlo
simulation for you guys and show you
what proton stopping in matter looks
like so this is a program called srem or
the stopping range of ions and matter it
uses the formulas that will be deriving
and developing in this class to
calculate the trajectory of protons in
anything so let's say you are made
basically of water so let's say you
consists of hydrogen and oxygen in a
stoichiometric ratio of 2 to 1 I think
water approximates humans pretty well so
we'll find out what the range of these
actual protons is in humans so what we
do know is that
it's a proton accelerator and I know
that the MGH accelerator has an energy
of 250 MeV or 250 thousand kill electron
volts and finally we decide how thick is
the person so how thick is a person
typically how many what units do we get
how many centimeters thick is the
average person let's go the the shortest
distance in so you know front to back
maybe 10 right 10 centimeters about that
much they get halfway through you only
have to go halfway because you can
always lie in your stomach all right
let's go ten centimeters most of the
protons go screaming right through you
you notice they don't actually stop in
the person so you don't tend to
irradiated
two hundred fifty MeV protons directly
you'll actually slow down their energy
to something a little more reasonable
maybe fifty MeV and then you can
actually watch each of these charged
particle tracks being computed as it
hits let's say imaginary nuclei or
electrons the paths will be slightly
deflected but what's really striking is
they all tend to stop at about the same
place that's the really cool thing about
charged particle interactions is if you
know the charge you know the nucleus you
know the energy you can calculate the
range to within a very narrow margin and
what this is doing is just flying looks
like it's done 70 ion so far and it will
keep on flying them until either you hit
the end let's say we set it to do a
hundred thousand atoms or you just tell
it to stop also when you don't have to
draw the lines it goes way faster so
let's let it get maybe three or 400 ions
and we'll show you what the average
range of the protons looks like how far
do they go before they stop if we look
at the ion distribution it's pretty
striking all of the protons except it
looks like one of them stopped at a very
fixed depth of forty-one point
nine millimeters with very little
straggle maybe point six millimeters on
either side so depending on the depth of
that you can even get a deep very
shallow very small tumor if you get the
distance just right in the proton energy
just right this is why proton therapy
centers are popping up all over the
world this is a much more effective
though expensive treatment for certain
types of tumors at the same time since
we're nuclear engineers we may be
concerned with the amount of radiation
damage being done to different materials
and so this is kind of a measure of how
much energy the protons are losing as
they travel through notice it's not zero
as soon as the protons enter the person
they start to scatter around undergoing
some different interactions but they
mostly don't lose much energy until they
reach almost their target depth and
what's called the stopping power is very
low at high energies very high at low
energies which means once they get slow
enough they almost all stop right there
what's called the Bragg peak and that's
the basis behind proton therapy and
you'll be able to understand why every
feature this curve looks the way it does
by the end of this course probably by
the end of this month so let me stop
that simulation because you really could
go on forever what we won't then the
question is what do you do if the tumors
too big if the tumor is larger than that
struggling you actually have to sweep
the energy of the proton beam so you can
vary the energy continuously what's
called intensity modulated radiation
therapy where you change the energy of
the proton sweep it back and forth
across the tumor to cover the whole
thing so you can sweep out in 3d space
the size of whatever you want to die
without affecting the stuff that you
don't want to die so in this case let's
say you'll apply protons of a certain
energy for some point and then another
energy that another energy and you can
maximize the dose to a pretty flat level
while minimizing the rest of the dose to
the patient so even while changing
energies the most dose is done to the
tumor and as little as possible is done
to the rest of the person we already
talked about brachytherapy but we didn't
say why it
works this is the first major topic
we'll be talking about in this course it
relies on natural radioactive decay and
for natural radioactive decay you need
to understand decay diagrams which are
energy level diagrams of which isotopes
turn into which others by which methods
and how much energy they release in each
type of decay so for example a common
run is iridium 192 a pretty bio
compatible isotope because it's well
it's like a noble metal and iridium 192
can decay by one of three pathways and
become platinum 192 gaining a proton
gaining a proton what has to happen for
that to be conserved so let's think
about this let's say we have platinum
192 which decays naturally into iridium
192 I can tell you because we've drawn
the diagram to the right it's going up
one atomic number so let's just say that
it had n protons and it now has n plus
one how do we balance this nuclear
reaction what are we missing yep
[Music]
it's in the new okay so there's a
neutron somewhere in this nucleus that
turns into a proton what are the three
and what are the things that we have to
conserve in any nuclear reaction yep yes
thank you I got that backwards but the
numbers are right the symbols are wrong
something else I'll mention about this
class please do stay on your toes to
correct silly things like that
I don't do scripts because you didn't
come here to see me read off a piece of
paper
everything's live all the derivations
are gonna be live because it's more
interesting certainly more interesting
for me to teach so thank you for
catching that and please do stay on your
toes if you see something silly
especially if it's just not the same as
on the screen so like Luke said we made
a proton or a neutron turned into a
proton what's not conserved in this
reaction
yep charge how do we balance that well
let's add some other particles there's
got to be some sort of radioactive decay
so wonder what are our choices of
particles yep sure an electron or more
specifically we'll call it a beta
particle just like a gamma ray is a
photon that originates in the nucleus a
beta particle is an electron that
originates in a nucleus you can't tell
it's a beta particle just by looking at
an electrons and electron the only way
you'd know is either by its energy or by
cuz there another source of electrons
nearby so in this case we get beta decay
this looks fairly balanced one thing
that I'll put in is beta decay is
accompanied by an anti neutrino but I
did not expect anyone to know that I
just want to make sure it's up there for
completeness so what we're relying on is
the movement of these electrons which
are high charged and low mass which
means they're very low range which means
when you implant a brachytherapy seed
into a person the irradiation volume is
only as large as the energy of that beta
particle will allow the maximum energies
for these beta particles are given by
the differences between the starting and
the ending energy the way these diagrams
are constructed is your ending energy is
usually has an energy of zero which we
refer to as the ground state of that
isotope and all of these are relative
energies in MeV or mega electron volts
so for example this iridium 192 has a
40% chance of decaying by beta 2
Platinum 192 which means the electron
can have up to one point four five nine
seven MeV and if we know its energy we
know its maximum range so selecting the
right isotope and the right activity for
the right tumor is quite important
notice that there's also other ways in
which this thing can decay it might
release a beta particle of a lower
energy and reach what's called an
excited state of platinum 190
- which can then decay by just giving
off this extra 612 kV of energy to the
ground state so let's write that nuclear
reaction let's say we have Platinum 192
and I'll put a star to mention that it's
excited becomes platinum 192 where the
energy go gamma so why do you say a
gamma ray
so you said it's because it's the
biggest source of energy that could be
released okay what do you think
indeed if an electron drops down in
energy levels that review will have
release an x-ray or a photon but that's
not a gamma-ray it's not coming from the
nucleus yep exactly
so the question with this is what do we
have to conserve mass momentum energy
charge we have Platinum 192 going to
platinum 192 the mass is pretty much the
same yep question Luke what is it means
it's at a higher energy nuclear state it
means that there is excess energy in
this nucleus so the difference between
ground state or whatever of iridium 192
and the ground state a platinum 192 is
one point four five nine seven MeV
notice I'm not rounding don't round and
we can end up with a beta particle that
doesn't quite release all that energy
leaving some in the nucleus in what's
called an excited state it's analogous
to if you have let's say an atom of a
whatever that happens to be and since
you started talking about different
electron energy levels maybe this atom
is helium and it only has two electrons
and one of them gains some energy
becoming excited up to the next energy
level same thing but on the nuclear
level these excitations are not in the
easy range there in the MeV range but
you can think of it as a precisely
analogous process for the time being
there are excited nuclear energy levels
and they can also decay by photon
emission in this case gamma emission
because the masses are basically the
same remember that the rest mass energy
might be slightly different but the
charge is the same there's no real
change in momentum because this is a
nucleus that started at rest and this
way the energy can be conserved yeah
Sean
in different cases
absolutely so there are multiple
isomeric transitions or gamma rays so if
let's chart one of the paths through
here there's a 14 percent chance that
iridium decays to this excited state and
it can then decay by a gamma ray to
another excited state and then decay to
ground so there are lots of different
possible pathways I've chosen a
particularly simple isotope because it
fits on the slide in your homework
you're going to get to look at the
decaying diagram for plutonium-239 there
are not enough pixels in this projector
to show the full complexity of that so
you'll have to zoom in a little bit but
I'm not going to ask you to do anything
with it except for look at the three
most likely transitions out of dozens
maybe scores who knows you guys will see
so that's a good question yeah it can
decay from an excited state to an
excited state to an excited state whoo
an excited state to an excited state and
so on until it reaches the ground state
it wouldn't be fishing products but
everything else you said is yes it can
continue to lose energy by continuously
undergoing radioactive decay and we're
gonna go some of this when we explore
the orally early origins of the universe
to say if you just started off with a
soup of protons and other things you'd
start to form all the isotopes possible
and the shortest half-life ones would
then decay successive decays may be
multiple gammas are multiple betas or
multiple alphas at the same time I'm
sorry in sequence until it reached
something that was stable or stable
enough that it's still around now for
example there's no stable isotope of
uranium
there's no isotope of uranium that will
not undergo alpha or spontaneous fission
it's just that the half-life is so long
that there's still some left since the
universe began there's still a fair bit
left but you guys are going to actually
calculate as part of your homework later
in the course how much uranium-235 was
there when the earth was born and how
much has just disappeared because of the
passage of time so right now it's
typically about 0.7% u-235 by ASSA topic
composition it was not the case when the
earth was born but you guys will be able
to figure that out yeah it's a good
question and have a rant from me I think
has been in response I'll try and keep
my answers a little shorter oh here's a
crazy one not particularly crazy though
so this is molybdenum-99 decaying to
technetium-99 metastable there's lots of
possible decays but the most likely one
is right here the state above the ground
state at about a hundred forty KETV a
fairly low energy and therefore more
easy to detect Photon
so if you notice almost all the other
excited states with a couple exceptions
decay down to this point one for MeV
excited state at which point you get two
caves to the ground state those also
have a rather long half-life it's a few
days so you can make Molly 99 in a
reactor transported to a hospital feed
it to someone
use these hundred 40 ke V gamma rays
because they come from the nucleus to
image whatever the technetium will bond
to yep touching the M stands for
metastable now where do you see it this
one yep because the direct decay you
don't you never go from molybdenum-99 to
technetium-99 at the ground state the M
stands for metastable so it's an excited
state and metastable tells you that it's
got a pretty long half-life all of these
other states are excited States
metastable means it's kind of sort of
stable on like a human time scale of
things it's not technically stable
because stable would mean infinite
half-life close enough but metastable
means long enough to be detected or used
or significantly longer than the others
any other questions before I move on
cool so you can use these to image where
something is in the body for example you
can use this to highlight certain organs
highlight anything that you can that
will absorb technetium or if you attach
let's say the technetium to a type of
sugar or something else that will be up
taken by the body you can see where it
goes and you can use gamma ray imagers
to make kind of heat maps or radiation
maps of where the technetium is going to
find what could be causing the problem
the problem is well our main problem is
there are huge mali 99 shortages right
now the only economically viable way to
make molybdenum-99 is in reactors and
there's only a few of these places in
the world that actually make them and
yeah I don't see any on the US we get
ours from Canada and these are slowly
getting closed down as we go so the
question is with millions of these
diagnostic procedures per year where is
the mali 99 going to come from that
might be where some of you guys come in
you can use the knowledge from this
course to figure out an energetically
and economically feasible way to make
more mali 99 you're rich that's you know
life goal achieved space applications if
we ever want to get off this earth for a
significant amount of time
we have to deal with the fact that
there's no atmosphere in space to shield
us from the high-energy protons and
other cosmic rays that would otherwise
well destroy life so there's a lot of
interesting ideas and a lot of problems
with astronauts shielding one of them is
that the protons are so heavy I'm sorry
the protons are so energetic that
they're difficult to shield just by mass
attenuation the trick here is well
different radiation has different
penetrating power it depends on its
energy but it also depends a lot on its
charge for example alpha particles can
be stopped by a sheet of paper these at
the MeV level helium nuclei like if you
hold an alpha particle source in your
hand the dead skin on your hand stops
the alphas from getting in remember that
because I'm gonna be asking you a
question later on to see who your
friends are and who they aren't I don't
know if anyone knows what I'm talking
about but if you do don't give it away
beta particles or electrons have low
mass and half the charge of an alpha
particle they tend to be able to get
through paper even through a little bit
of plastic but a small bit of metal can
stop them
gamma rays go right through and notice
that they've been drawn not quite being
stopped by the concrete which is a great
shielding material because like I said
before you can exponentially attenuate
gamma rays you can't with all certainty
stop every single one so then how do you
stop these high-energy charged particles
if the more energetic they are the more
range they are boost your
electromagnetic field so it's actually
been proposed to have spaceships with
enormous magnetic fields or
electromagnetic fields around them to
deflect the protons away or around the
ship because if you can't stop it by
putting matter in the way rely on the
fact that they're charged particles and
will curve around whatever's got a high
electric field around it so this is one
way of let's say shielding deep-space
missions
you can't put more stuff in there
because stuff is heavy and launching
stuff into space is expensive rely on
electromagnetism and there are also RTG
their radio thermal generators or
radioisotope thermoelectric generators
which are little balls of things like
plutonium or strong tea
that give off so many alpha particles
and the alpha particles have very low
range they deposit their kinetic energy
as heat in the material and cause them
to glow on their own if you produce
enough heat if something's glowing red
you can use thermoelectric generators to
capture that heat and turn it directly
into electricity this is how things like
Voyager and let's see all the other
space probes with interesting names are
powered once you're too far from the Sun
for solar power to work you need
something that doesn't turn off so you
can use RTGS
which have long enough half-lives to
produce significant amounts of power for
a long time but short enough half flies
so that their activity is pretty high
and they release a lot of energy as
radiation and that radiation is heavy
charged particles but you can capture as
heat so yeah an actual little sphere of
plutonium that produces a hundred watts
just sitting there there is no way to
turn it off that's the end of the
sentence it's plutonium and finally
there's nuclear rockets if you think
about using a reactor for thrust instead
of electrical energy the design of the
reactor gets very different for example
you can start to let things get a whole
lot hotter when there's no oxygen in
space to oxidize things and your
propellant maybe would be liquid
hydrogen that doesn't burn but goes
through the reactor gets accelerated
turned into a gas with a high kinetic
energy to fire out the back of the
rocket nozzle and provide the thrust
that you need and so it's nuclear
rockets that would really be the only
feasible way without bending space-time
which I don't think we've really done
yet - in order to get to very distant
stars like that planet they just found
orbiting Proxima Centuri 4 light-years
away pretty close right no not really if
you think about how a nuclear rocket
mission would would work well it doesn't
have to have nearly as much thrust
especially if you start from orbit maybe
use a chemical rocket to launch yourself
into orbit and then spend half your
journey accelerating very very slowly
and then turn the rocket around spend
the other half of this journey
decelerating very very slowly so you
need a long constant but low level
thrust for these long-lived nuclear
mission
I'm gonna stop here because it's five
minutes before the hour we only have a
few more of these things to go through
but what I will ask is you guys hang
tight for the next few minutes while
these guys take the cameras apart we're
gonna go to my lab and see an
application of nuclear which like I said
is plasma sputter coating
all right everyone so welcome to my
laboratory this is the mesoscale nuclear
materials group where we make and break
materials for nuclear technology usually
not in that order but whatever we get it
done somehow and this is read to knock
out one of my graduate students who's
actually repaired I'm going to show you
the physical principles and operation of
a sputter coder which is nothing more
than a controlled radiation damage
machine and he'll be making some
interesting door prizes for you guys oh
my Kurt said this is Professor Mike
sorts calling something else I call it
the home the rehabilitated home for old
orphaned equipment and old friends and
so this is actually this piece of gear
here and did a little research on it and
I think it was built about the same time
as I was entering college 35 years so
about 1978 maybe 98 that's policy now so
that's a short goes around as all of us
that we sprouted we scavenger and
if you look at it and talk to a little
bit but there's a procedure of this that
we've gotten rich out we don't know so
what you're gonna see is a little
demonstrate fitter smarter cutter it
allows your scooters wheat under vacuum
right now back is pressure there's our
vacuum are there come right here so you
can see both or again there's another
reputation but we don't discuss that one
alright without further ado like we did
power off we're gonna put up the center
of high-voltage its argon in here we've
got hard on supply sand that bottle over
there
we're not gonna - charts why turning it
up so we get the lights read I'll go get
him
I'll just get him right over where you
are you see through this glass bar
oh yeah come a little closer from where
I am you start to see the glowing purple
plasma so that's the ionization of the
argon causing it to electrostatically
accelerate towards the gold target and
that's blasting off gold atoms that are
then coating the stuff that reads
coating that you'll see in a second but
this is a controlled application of
ionization and radiation damage using a
couple of kilovolt argon ion don't know
if you call it a beam but at least an
argon ion plasma
so there's a few other things to note
remember how we talked about charged
particles having a certain range and
matter well charge particles and let's
say low energy particles and the kv
range do not have a very high range even
in gases which is why reid has this
vacuum pump connected otherwise the
argon wouldn't make it to where it has
to do the damage so when there's too
much gas in there shuts off when there's
not enough argon in there there's no
argon to do the damage so we're actually
exciting about two kV ions and their
range is higher than the distance they
have to travel so they actually make it
where they're supposed to go this is a
kind of direct application of NSE along
with a fair bit of high voltage
electronics and that's pretty much all
there is to it yeah they'll get right in
there if you want to see if you look
underneath you'll actually see that a
blue glowing ring that's actually a ring
of gold that's being hit by the plasma
and that's causing gold ions to fire on
to the target
Oh
you should know that only the nukes can
do that right really all you got you got
to get away from all the electrons and
all that other chemistry stuff and only
the new so if you really want to turn
something to gold you got it to learn
the different
does everyone had a chance to get a
close-up look okay
anyone have any questions about what
you're seeing here it's a good question
the temperature does not go up that much
there's certainly kinetic energy turned
into thermal energy as the argon hits
the gold and the gold hits whatever
you're trying to coat but the total
amount of energy the density of that gas
is extremely low that's another reason
why in fusion reactors the plasma is up
to like millions or tens of millions of
Kelvin there's just not a lot of it so
if you look at the total amount of
stored thermal energy in a fusion
reactor it's quite low even though the
temperature or the relation to the
average kinetic energy of the molecules
is extremely high yeah good question you
want put your hand up to the side of the
chamber it's a warm
not at all yep
the plasma is
there we go yeah we'll open it up and
show you so I'll get the lights on now
yeah from the point that we when you
walked in and saw that yeah okay the
first thing the first thing so this had
a sort of a static amount of argon in it
and when I turn on the voltage the high
voltage that's thick that's it to create
the plasma but then it has to get fed so
what I ended up doing with this little
knob for a price to explain that it's
out speeding in argon but they are got
bottles of coke in here it's going into
this when you're feeding the argon into
the pressure p1 if the pressure comes up
too high on this particular instrument
and it has an automatic cutoff for the
Michael to spits out because otherwise
you know one of the reason why it works
is because we have so few atoms in there
deal with what happens when director is
important 7:16
right
have a little bit although this is that
that's the goal
in the chamber you can put the you can
put the ring facing down for stability
if you wanted that I said you can just
put the ring lying flat down if you want
for stability yeah
anger
purpose of happiness actually this
machine the main reason is if you have
something that you want to put into a
scanning electron microscope and
we're actually gonna use one of those in
plots so you have some kind of coating
on it so if you're looking at nothing
like the fire log something that's
conductive and so there you see about I
would guess I think as long as we did it
for something on the end on the level
above 200 that's all you need though yep
remember after quiz number one we will
be piloting or well two of you guys will
be piloting a scanning electron
microscope down in the basement and
before we look at whatever samples you
want to see whether it's your one of
your eyelash there's dust on the floor
or a bug you found or something we'll
want to coat it in gold so that the
electrons that we use for imaging will
have a place to go
well of a conductive path and they won't
charge up ruining the image I have a
question yeah as anybody was anybody
here for this millennia one 2000 or
later nobody in one 1999 nobody in 1990
honey
how about 98 Google for 298 there we go
alright that would be
at the 1998 die
now gold-coated
that
right so you win this it'll rub off okay
so thank you guys might you put it up on
eBay and build teams yes the other ones
go to people that
oh no 97 out of 96 oh there's 396 okay
you guys
all right what's the nipple at the 96
you know oh yeah right fun you read
you got the armwrestling it's a quarter
and it's parked out there for ya
that's not a nuclear thing but it's fun
actually breathe into it that's just
okay yeah so there's the goal deposited
anywhere else
yeah if you look actually if you look at
the neighbors I mean this is all this is
all being smarter than if you look
around so it actually it gets everywhere
but it's mostly directed in that area
that you saw them I have another offer
are all going to be in all but one but
we have a new kethu Xia so otherwise
wouldn't be in this class and anyone
scared of nuclear is probably not in
this class so obviously is pretty easy
for us to do we have this machine here I
mean I can even supply I'm I feel rich
enough I could because all those
graduates graduate school
but aren't anything else any questions
for Reid what you just saw the goal is
to sort of give you a real life you know
learn 2201 you'll understand how these
things work and how you can modify them
create new stuff that's a general idea
same thing behind looking at the
electron microscope or the focused ion
beam EDX elemental analysis I want to
bring what we're teaching you to life as
often as we can
since we only got one recitation a week
we'll be doing it about that much once
in a while I may schedule some extra
stuff as long as folks who are available
but we're gonna try all we can to have
days like this we get to see what you're
learning in real life because the
process of the argon hitting the goal is
actually known as sputtering which is
the blasting off of surface atoms by
energetic particles it's a controlled
form of radiation damage
Swagelok they're all in UV what Swagelok
companies oh here we go yeah this is
Swagelok tubing it's got a two-piece
ferrule which does make some metal to
metal seal for moving liquid or gas and
it takes an insanely high pressure so
actually over in the next room we can
look on our way out
we've built a reactor simulator like an
experimental reactor that replicates all
the conditions except for the radiation
we have to make it entirely out of
Swagelok tubing because this stuff can
hold the pressure and the temperature
without deforming too much so when you
want to make an absolutely airtight seal
use things Swagelok or things like it
this is stainless steel yep they make it
out of titanium or other things too but
stainless steel works for us
PWR how much pressure is in a PWR
there's a hundred and fifty atmospheres
of pressure it's also 150 atmospheres of
pressure over in the room next door like
I said it's all the same conditions as a
reactor except the radiation the
pressure is what makes it really
dangerous yeah we'll look through the
one of the few bulletproof glass shields
because if anything blows on that loop
it's like it is a projectile we've only
had one explosion there was no
temperature at the time but it sounded
like a like a shotgun blast over the
side of your shoulder it was loud the
loop was right here and we were right in
front of it then the loop jumped up
maybe an inch and we jumped up about
three feet we got scared
that was what happens when you
improperly torque a high pressure
fitting because you've actually got to
tighten these nuts down to not too low
and not too high of a torque otherwise
they don't seal and usually only find
out that they don't seal when they're
approaching close to their rated thing
you're like great it's not half pressure
it's all okay you reach 99% pressure and
kaboom that's what happened cool
thanks a lot Reid for showing this to us
and taking time out of your day anytime
hope you guys enjoyed it so no problems
to work through this week that's gonna
change starting Tuesday next class so
have a good weekend and I'll see you
guys all on Tuesday in room 24 115 next
to the room where we were just in
you